chevaux préparer cavaliers affûté il y a
comme un frémissement sur les terrains
de concours c'est que le printemps
annonce aussi la reprise des
compétitions de sports équestres
la deuxième édition du salon cheval au
centre marque le coup d'envoi de la
saison comment se porte l'équitation en
région centre val de loire
howell se porte pas si mal que ça c'est
sûr qu'on n'est plus dans les grands
belle de l'année mais franchement on
repasse plaindre aujourd'hui on a des
progressions progression dans le nombre
de cavaliers qui font la compétition ça
c'est important pour nous comité
régional combien oles d'année ont fait 8
% d'augmentation sur les cavaliers
amateurs ce qui comme un pape aurait de
la france et par rapport à la morosité
générale pas mal moins chez ac comptant
plus de pratiquants ça veut dire plus de
chevaux d'instruction dans les centres
équestres et justement sur le salon une
vingtaine de chevaux et poneys sont
proposés à la vente
il effectue un petit parcours
d'obstacles destinée à montrer leur
maniabilité et leur bonne volonté
indispensable pour ne pas effrayer les
apprentis cavaliers
la première qualité d'un cheval de club
c'est vraiment qu'il soit bien dans sa
tête
pratique pour les pour les jeunes bien
dans sa tête
un exemple qu'il fasse pas un écart s'il
ya un peu de vent vraiment pratique dans
sa tête
après on ne parle pas vraiment de
qualité parce que n'importe quel cheval
va pouvoir sauter ce qu'on saute dans
les poney club ou dans les centres
équestres donc la première qualité c'est
bien dans sa tête
l'équitation pour tous c'est aussi
l'équitation pour les handicapés et la
grande nouveauté du salon cette année
cette épaule yb un système entièrement
modulable conçu en partenariat avec
l'école nationale d'équitation et le
cadre noir de saumur
bonjour ça sert à kiel ce module est
adaptée quel type de handicap
ça va fonctionner sur plusieurs types de
pathologies on va avoir des enfants
polyhandicapés
on va avoir des paraplégiques des
tétraplégiques
ça va servir à beaucoup de personnes
différentes c'est surtout ça va
fonctionner pour un enfant comme pour un
adulte parce que lee paul iv
complètement modulable
on voit ils nous voient pas cette règle
ouais alors donc cette partie là la
partie avant va venir sur les crêtes
iliaque
ensuite on va pouvoir régler la
profondeur donc par exemple si on a un
enfant on reviendra plus sur le devant
et ensuite on va régler le dossier
démonstration tout de suite avec adeline
elle est atteinte du syndrome d'ehlers
danlos une maladie orpheline proche de
la myopathie qu elle monte à cheval
depuis l'âge de 13 ans mais sa maladie
évolutive la handicape de plus en plus à
au moins un acheteur c'est à l'âge peut
laisser aller elle teste pour la
première fois il polit ben ali en est
reparti avec sa monture habituelle
arturo
l'audition ouais là devant ça fait du
bien même pas derrière ça me garde une
wii on semble maintenu et on se sent
vraiment en sécurité on se dit là c'est
bon j'ai vraiment un petit cocon autour
de moi ne peut rien arriver
l'équitation c'est avant tout du rêve
le salon est aussi l'occasion de tester
les futurs cracks des jeunes chevaux de
trois ou quatre ans au pedigree
prometteur et qui montrent leurs
qualités à l'obstacle en liberté